so I had a couple ideas on asset at this
music festival hmm one I want to run by
you and then one it was fun time by the
way what music festival Firefly in
Delaware nice the bus from New York and
then you just go there camp and a
[ __ ] good time and I'm [ __ ]
alright just like laying down on my back
trying to keep my eyes open so I can my
friends went off to the bath and like
you'll be here Mike I'll be right here
I'm not coming anywhere right now
and so keep my eyes of you look at you
like what's wrong with you you know just
see a few stars and you'd be out of it
eyes open but just out of it and then
everyone's I [ __ ] love music
festivals man you come out of it and
there's some [ __ ] guy dressed like a
wooden him [ __ ] that's great
anyway I said I just heard somebody go I
never want to get that [ __ ] up [ __ ]
Sarris idea you know I do those album
breakdowns my first album breakdown yeah
I want to do one with you on Sam Kinison
salbo oh just let's listen to it like
talk about it and yeah yeah let's do it
let's do louder than hell do you know
louder than hell you can't get on CD
because it was so slow mo phobic that
the people of Warner Brothers they put
it out on cassette but then they never
released it on CD when CDs came on them
like [ __ ] that fat slob Wow really
forget let me tell you how much he had
to overcome I was around during the PC
days of the 80s we're in a PC war right
now seems like it's just a battlefield
it's just gone crazy like there's more
bombs going off PC wise than ever people
are so invested in the idea of
controlling behavior and telling people
what to do but back then it was
happening to for a while yeah with the
remember the music or Al Gore's wife
their wife is trying but there's some
things that go too far yeah she was
trying to ban rap music and so things
got things got real weird same language
over and over new MTV banned Dice Clay
for life because he told some joke about
girls in their periods or something
I'd love to hear what that joke was and
see if we can actually like that's a
goddamn badge of courage for a guy like
dice just gave him a gold medal that's
all it really does for him he doesn't
give a [ __ ] that guy legitimately
doesn't give a [ __ ] like I was ever
going to be anyway
he walks around he makes videos walking
around the supermarket talking about his
haircut I got this new haircut what do
you think nah make another video this
[ __ ] haircut that guy doesn't give a
[ __ ]
like literally he's just doing whatever
dice wants to do wandering through the
world hanging out with his kids so like
for him like getting banned from MTV's
probably the greatest thing ever this is
it wow that bravado there look at him
come on man oh my god that's bro who's
the best what the [ __ ] you were just a
zebra welcome you to this event my name
is dice I'm here to say I was born in
Brooklyn
Sheepshead Bay come a long way to make
your smile I'm gonna do it if we're
gonna do it dice style what is this is
this playing on YouTube or is it not
true rewind that look how [ __ ]
nervous he is
look it's closed hand around look at
shaking dice I'm here to say I was born
in Brooklyn Sheepshead Bay come a long
way to make your smile I'm gonna do it
different gonna do it nice style
you seem shaken yeah it's all bravado
and then he's like I'm doing this that
was the weirdest kind of comedy that he
could do it if they knew what you were
gonna say they wanted to hear it roses
are common a complete original complete
original if you just like people look at
him like all brutish and disgusting and
just the dirty jokes and misogynist all
those things are true but but you gotta
realize that he revolutionized like he
did something he but he broke through a
rock star style also if you just look at
it completely objectively forget about
the artistic merits of what he did he
did something very different he figured
out a way to do comedy that people
legitimately laughed at even though they
knew it was coming
yeah that hadn't been done before that
hadn't been really like that never know
I am of your right never no one yells
out the punchlines in front with no
crowd what's in the bow [ __ ] you know
he needed the money
Oh everybody wanted to hear the things
that he had already said which never
existed before he could [ __ ] tour
with that original act right now and
people would be super satisfied let's
say along with um sad [ __ ] yeah dice
could do 10,000 seat arenas with an
original act what's in the bowl [ __ ]
that's not much goes nowhere
nothing comedy-wise nothing it's the
opposite of regular comedy sup